tiger king joe exotic's 22-year prison  sentence for  trying to kill carol baskin is being  vacated but don't worry  he is not getting out of jail basically  the trial court said that joe exotic had  two different plans to kill carol baskin  and as a result  in his sentencing he got a higher  sentence than he should have because the  10th circuit said that he can't kill  someone more than once and all of this  was part of the same plan to kill carol  baskin so the amount of time that he was  actually sentenced should be  slightly less so he was sentenced to 22  years in jail that might be reduced to  about 17 years in jail instead  so joe exotic is not going free he'll be  re-sentenced so we will see him  in court